Sudan is a diverse country in terms of
cautious and religious but I have never
found my story in the schoolbooks my
name is Alberto Ibrahim have done I am
the operation commander in a mobile
force and I have led more than 75
buttons racism is everywhere in Sudan
especially in the north of the country
we experience it in our homes in the
streets and in the schools it makes a
person from the Nuba Mountains feel like
a third-class citizen racism makes it
very hard to live in a society where you
are not equal to your countrymen
[Music]
President Bashir says this year will be
the end of espionage in the Nuba
Mountains he says he will send 100
planes two bombers
[Music]
the problem of these countries that the
leaders don't listen to the voice of
change but they do listen to the sound
of bullets
[Music]
we cannot let over Beshear humiliates
don't know
we will push the gas pedal 10
[Music]
a bobble sometimes they call it society
but we accept this sick people I have
two families my soldiers and my family
at home from November to June I'm in the
battlefield and I don't see my family at
home but I remember them
[Music]
my father didn't want me to be a soldier
I don't want my son to wear a uniform my
greatest hope is that I'm fighting so my
son will not be a third class citizen if
I want him to be a Sudanese citizen